こんにちははじめ社長ですもう知っている方もいると思いますがなんとこのたび私
弾み車上等
あの有名ブランドサマンサタバサさんとこの後送金を浮かべていただきました
[音楽]
サマンサ田端ですよよすごくかわいくてこう羽あのイメージがあってあのそのような
女の子らしいブラウンとと私のような
こんなオトコ女がうこれはずバッグとか t シャツ作らせていただいたんですけども
やっぱり大実に普通に使ってもらいたいっていうことで結構デザインとか玉 the
sun の一つをすごいいろいろ考えて作らせていただきました
で今回ですねこれをきっかけにサマンサタバサのイベントに登壇させて頂いたり
ガールズアワードのランウェイを挙げさせていただいているしたのでぜひそちらの模様
頃
くださいどうぞえっ
水すぎるいい
[音楽]
ムラーノ影ロンブーああああ
par
[音楽]
bap
benan
t 4
[音楽]
me
ume
wh
[音楽]
[拍手]
voodoo
その後遊園地とばてるはい仲良く冷凍
[音楽]
voodoo
ana
ああああああ
who ん
[音楽]
shani
4日入っというわけで以下が経ったでしょうか余談なんですけど何名で歩くときは
めっちゃ
してよくね駄目だったんですけどウォーキングの先生に
姿勢がクソ悪いってめちゃくちゃ怒られましたありがとうございますはいそして今回の
コラボ商品なんですけどもパックが3種類ありますまず一つ目がこちら
カジュアルとうとう専用スレ
あるんですけどもなんか個人的に青だったら男の子でも使えるんじゃないかなと思って
おります
全然ありだと思うもう抱えたところ座の顔がチャームポイントです
そしてキャンパスバック2種類ありますね姫ちゃんのやつと所沢のやつですね
そしてこちらキャンバストートところ山のめぐみちゃんが服を着てハートに囲まれて
可愛い二人寄り添っております可愛い
こちらところ里めぐみちゃんのチャームも行っております
バッグにちょっとつけておくだけでもめちゃくちゃ
が可愛いですね
であとは t シャツを誤植準備しました
ナマズはこちら j ぜーぜー
b まあざーディーラー
なんとかあの
日本語で言うとビックいて日本を書いていないバージョンと日本語が書いてある
バージョンがあります
白紺井六郎グレーピンクの5色準備しました
そしてですねお店の方に様 the clover くるっていうお菓子が売ってるん
ですけども
ぞ様ザクロワークでもところ that めぐみちゃんのコラボ商品として作って
もらったのでぜひ食べてみてください
こちらのコラボ商品なんですけども買える場所が決まっておりまして
サマンサタバサアニバーサリー東京スカイツリータウンソラマチ店様 the 高さも
てさんとゲイツ
ポップアップデジタルストアでも販売しておりましてオンラインネットでも買えるん
ですけども
web の公式 ec サイト名でも買えますので動画の概要欄に載せておきますので
ぜひそちらからをチェックしてみてください
ぜひ男の子も女の子も買ってみてください
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ